[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER: This is
where it happens.
With a smile, a skillful
touch, a thoughtful look.
The morning rush,
an evening stroll.
Out in the cold but always
warm, we are the front line.
Hear us.
See how we work together.
With Chromebooks
in our hands we'll
be faster, more connected,
and better informed.
We'll keep going the distance.
And we'll always have you back.
Because we are the front line.
[END PLAYBACK]
MIKE DAOUST: Hi everyone.
Thanks for joining
us this afternoon
to learn how to turn your
front line workers into
cloud workers with
Chrome Enterprise.
You'd be amazed at how long
it took Lesley to train me how
to do that sequence I just did.
It took a bit.
It's getting late in the
day, but thanks again
for taking the time.
My name is Mike Daoust.
I head up our Chrome
Enterprise Go To Market team.
And I have the privilege
to kick things off today.
And we'll walk you
through some research
that we've done around
this frontline worker
segment, and some great
understandings in how
the cloud can help here, as
well as Chrome Enterprise,
and then walk you through
some use cases with companies
that we've worked with to date.
And then I'll hand things
over to Ravi, who leads up IT
for Stitch Fix, a company
that hopefully most of you
have all heard and utilized.
And he'll take you
through real life examples
that he's encountered with his
frontline workers and Chrome
Enterprise.
Hopefully we'll have
time for questions.
We got about 45 minutes.
If you haven't been to any
sessions and utilized the Dory,
this is the capability.
You can see the
instructions here
that if you have some thoughts
as we go through the content,
and you want to submit a
question, feel free to do that.
And then if we have time at
the end we will utilize this.
We'll also take live
questions here as well.
So before we dive into the
frontline worker, first
I want to talk a little
bit about the cloud worker.
This is a narrative
we kicked off,
actually, this time last year.
And it was a bunch
of research we
did across 1,400 ID
decisionmakers and users
with Forrester.
And it was really
interesting research,
that really at the end of the
day, to sum it up, it said,
everyone in their day-to-day
lives, their personal lives,
is operating in the cloud.
They leverage content,
they leverage applications,
no matter what location
in their personal lives.
Whether it's
Netflix and Spotify,
whether it's getting to
work using Google Maps,
with Uber and Lyft,
they're used to having
information applications
at their fingertips
to make their day
truly efficient.
And they've taken that same
expectation into Enterprises
and handed that problem,
so to speak, to many of you
in the room here today.
But what was interesting about
the research at the time,
is last year, basically, it
found that about a quarter
of the folks within
any organization,
small, medium, or large,
are cloud workers.
They're ready.
They're ready to
adopt the cloud.
Their expectations are
there, and the excitement
and the opportunity is there.
And it's only grown as more
workloads move to the cloud,
as the SaaS sort of
steam train continues
to triple year-on-year
growth, this
is becoming more
and more reality.
And really it's
something that we
see as a tremendous opportunity
for this frontline worker
segment.
At the end of the day, I
think in the old world,
how you worked or what your job
category was sort of determined
what you needed on
a day-to-day basis.
And the reality is, now, it's
not really where you work
but how you work,
and what you need
to do on a day-to-day basis.
And anyone can fundamentally
be a cloud worker today.
Whether they traditionally
are an information worker,
whether they're out in the
field, in the back office,
they can be a cloud worker.
But what's interesting is that
the segment that often gets
forgotten-- and I'll
walk through this
a little bit-- is
this frontline worker
in terms of taking the
cloud to them so that they
can be more effective
and efficient in driving
the organization strategy.
Who are these frontline workers?
Interestingly enough, it's
about 80% of the workforce.
These are these deskless workers
that aren't like some of us,
sort of chained to a desk.
They're cashiers, they're
call center agents,
they're project managers that
could be on construction sites,
they're nurses, they're EMTs.
They're out there in the
field working hand-in-hand,
selling products, supporting
products and services,
and are very much the face and
the backbone of any company,
or most companies that
are out there today.
They directly impact the CX,
or the customer experience.
And this customer experience has
huge top line and bottom line
impact.
As you can see here from the
Gartner study, 90% of companies
compete primarily based
on customer experience.
And you can see the "Harvard
Business Review" sort of backs
that up with people
that have had
a positive past
purchase will spend
140% more on their next one.
And I think we can
all relate to that.
I, way, way, way back when,
when I was in the restaurant
business and was a
frontline bartender, waiter,
what have you, or worked
in the hotel business,
I had managers that always
said if a customer has
a bad experience,
they're properly
going to tell 5
to 10 more people
than they would if
they had a good one.
So this has both a positive
and negative impact.
And executives and companies
are seeing this and measuring
the performance of this.
However, the same token,
these same leaders
feel like the
investment isn't there
in these frontline workers--
not giving them
the tools they need
to really elevate and meet
the needs of this customer
experience.
And you can see it here in
terms of the frontline worker
managers themselves and
those actual workers.
75% of them feel like they don't
have consistent communication
to really carry the message,
both from a compliance
standpoint and a
strategy standpoint,
to their customers to
do their day-to-day job.
So it's a huge missed
opportunity in many ways.
And again, it's,
interestingly enough,
validated by both the leaders
within these organizations
as well as the frontline worker
managers and their users.
We actually did some
surveying ourself
to sort of test
this out as well,
and asked both information
workers and frontline
workers what kind
of effect technology
has had in terms of
a positive effect
over the last past years--
past five years, sorry.
Information workers, 70% felt
like it had a positive effect.
Frontline workers,
one out of every two
said it had a positive impact.
So think about
that for a minute.
There has been a lot of
positive technical changes
in the marketplace, but still
only one out of every two
frontline workers actually feel
like it helps their experience
to do their job better, right?
So huge missed opportunity here.
But what does it all mean?
What does it result in?
Why should you care?
At the end of the day, is
that if you have disengagement
here-- and you can see
here, if you have pessimism
within this frontline
worker base,
and you can see the
statistics here.
Back in 2016, there
is a 66% turnover rate
within these frontline workers.
And underneath this is, if
you take a semi-average,
hourly employee-- they
make $30,000 a year--
research shows that about
20% to 25% of that salary
is needed to hire
the next employee.
So you can see how you get
to this hundreds of billions
of dollars of lost productivity
and revenue to companies
every year.
It's pretty staggering
and amazing.
It's not all bad news.
There is some good news here.
And the good news here
is we really think,
and we have some proof--
both from outside
research as well as
experiences with ourselves
and customers like Stitch
Fix-- that the cloud can
help solve this, right?
It can really help elevate
these frontline workers in terms
of their employee experience.
They're ready.
They, like all of us--
and some of them
may be in the room--
are using the cloud in their
day-to-day personal lives.
So their usage and their
expectation level is there.
And if they are more
engaged, and they
are having a more
positive experience,
that's going to pass on to
the customer experience,
and have that positive impact.
On top of that, the
cloud can really
deliver a higher
level of security.
And we've seen that
in Chrome Enterprise,
and we'll talk a
little bit about that.
And ideally-- and we've
seen this as well--
is going to deliver you a more
productive solution at a lower
cost.
So all of these elements are
really the positive light
that we want to talk a
little bit about in terms
of the opportunity that you
have with your frontline worker
segment.
For Chrome Enterprise, for
those of you that are not aware
of it, this really encompasses
Chrome browser, Chrome OS,
and Chromebooks, as well as
the management capabilities
that come with this offering.
You can see here on the
left side of the slide,
you have what it brings
to the business--
so folks that are here in the
room managing end points or end
users--
as well as on the
right, what benefits
it can bring to the users.
And I'll walk through
each aspect of this
as we go through
these slides here.
First of all, security.
I think those of you that have
been on of the Chrome journey
hopefully know at this point
that security is really
paramount, and probably
the first key pillar
to any feature, or
device, or functionality
that we roll out with Chrome.
And it really is
the highest bar,
both from browser, to OS, to any
Chrome device that's out there.
And we have multi
layers of security.
And we could definitely
take you through reviews.
But I think what we
can say confidently
is that most folks
that go through this
and look at it from
a security standpoint
are pretty well pleased.
We've put a lot
of work into sort
of isolating certain encrypted
profiles and management
of applications.
And the beauty of Chrome is that
it does update every six weeks.
And most all those updates
have security capabilities
that are added.
And those are things that
you can either take advantage
of or manage and roll those
out as time is needed, right?
But security is definitely a
really high bar, and a true
differentiator when it
comes to Chrome Enterprise.
From a licensing
standpoint, what you
get with the license
is a number of things.
But just to point out a
couple here is you get,
really, policy management across
your users and your end points.
So 200+ of them think of
it as if you have a segment
of users-- so a set of frontline
workers that are mobile
workers-- and you
have an application,
or a set of applications that
you want them to have access
to, you can push
those to those users.
You can also blacklist
certain applications
so they don't have
access to those.
So it gives you kind of a full
breadth of user management
in that regard.
You also have device management.
So that if a device
disappears or gets
lost you can essentially
disable that device
so it is non-operable and causes
no harm to your environment.
So it gives you
the full breadth.
And we're constantly
updating those policies.
We've also-- the product team's
done a phenomenal job working
with a set of our partners
that are in this EMM space
to open up our APIs so
that you can leverage,
if you've made investment
in any of these providers,
you can have that
single pane of glass
and still manage your
devices, like you may manage
a mobile device or any other
device you have in your fleet.
So we're trying to really help
bridge the gap between what
you've purchased in the past,
as well as sort of enabling
that for the future.
And then obviously you get a lot
of the common Enterprise 24/7
support that you would get
with any Enterprise offering.
Savings is a big piece of
this, and yeah, a couple of
slides here to
talk through that.
Google is a great example.
We still are a company that
allows ultimate flexibility
in terms of what types of
operating system and devices
you can utilize.
We're seeing, obviously,
a high growth, and Chrome
being a huge segment of that.
But you can see some of
the comparables here.
And I think it's
really something
that a lot of times
customers don't really
fathom until they've
experienced it
is that, one, the setup of
the device can be far simpler.
So you can see here it's
approximately 33 minutes
to set up a Chrome
device and close
to 2 and 1/2 hours for
a comparable device
with the other platforms.
And this is coming from
our IT support teams
at Google that are supporting
tens of thousands of these.
Once you have a device
out there in the field,
then there's the
support of that device.
And we measure that
ticket per 1,000 tickets
that are out there.
And it's about 19
tickets per 1,000
are Chrome tickets,
and almost 100
for a comparable windows device.
So we are a great
testament of the fact
that both the setup and the
support of these devices
is far lower than what we're
finding in our environment.
And we continue to
sort of pull this,
and happy to share some
of these statistics
with you if it'll help
in your engagements.
This multi-user experience,
again, is something that--
sometimes candidly, we struggle
to explain to companies
and the uniqueness of it.
And oftentimes when they
start to deploy Chrome,
sort of the light bulb goes off.
But in essence, you can have as
many encrypted cloud profiles
running on these devices.
So much like-- if you're
familiar with education,
and Chromebooks, and 60 plus
percent market share in the US
here, alone, is a big part
of that value proposition was
kids could jump
into a classroom,
pull a Chromebook off the shelf,
and use that in a secure way.
We've taken that to
the Enterprise as well,
so that amongst your frontline
workers, many of them
may have multiple shifts
throughout the course of a day.
And so you can have
those same set of devices
be used by a large magnitude of
frontline workers, by the way,
for a bunch of
different use cases.
So it securely
knows who you are,
what applications
you have access to.
You then can set it so that it
wipes automatically on log out,
or you can set it to time
out and wipe those devices.
So all the security
components are there.
The next front line
worker comes in can
pull that Chromebook off the
shelf and do what they need.
This is a piece that,
when I talk to any CIOs
right on down to the IT folks
that are managing devices,
really believe this
is unparalleled,
like the slide says, in terms
of a differentiated capability.
And it's something that
allows you, quite frankly,
to deploy less devices
out in the field,
but serve more users.
This again sort of speaks
a bit to the savings here.
Dave over Schnucks, a
grocery chain in the Midwest,
has been using Chromebooks.
And you can see
here, quite openly,
is saving $1,250 per
year on device costs.
And you could see on the
left-hand side, again,
it starts a bit with the
hardware and software
and initial investment.
There's a bit here in terms
of employee productivity.
So being able to be productive
on a day-to-day basis
is a component of it.
But I think again,
the 75% improvement
in terms of IT productivity and
savings on what IT is used to
is really a big proponent.
And I often say when I chat with
CXOs those that are out there,
they always have more
projects than people.
So if you can save
them time on this,
there's plenty of
projects for them
to pick up outside of managing
devices and end points.
And Chrome can give
you that capability.
I think, from a user
standpoint, a lot
of these things we've been
talking about for years,
but I think are good reminders.
The fact that a Chromebook can
boot up in about six seconds
is still pretty amazing.
A lot of us has been
living in that world,
so we forget the old world
of turn the device on, grab
a cup of coffee, come
back and be productive.
This again is something that
is definitely a differentiator
and continues to be a big
piece of the value proposition.
The cloud based profiles is
something I mentioned before.
The saved ID time.
And then basically,
quick access to what
you need to do on
a day-to-day basis.
And we're always trying to
incorporate things around ML
in the background,
with our partners
and with our
employees, to help make
it a more productive
experience on a device.
It's something that's unique to
allow them to do what they need
to do on a day-to-day basis.
In terms of form factors, we've
made a lot of progress here.
I think when I started
about six, seven years ago
we had one OEM and one
device that we were
deploying across the globe.
Now, you can see that every
major OEM has a set of devices
in the marketplace.
I think what's
pretty exciting, too,
is that it runs the gamut
in terms of form factor--
from tablet, to convertible,
to desktop, to clam shell.
And really, what's
great about it
when you think about your
segments within your workforce,
is everything from
lower end, to medium,
to really premium devices.
And I think we're really
excited for the future
here, because I
think we're going
to continue to build out
that portfolio with our OEM
partners.
So it gives you the
breadth and depth
you need to meet the needs
of not just your front line
workers, but in the future,
more and more your information
workers as well.
G Suite is something
here that we definitely
wanted to mention.
I think many of our
Chrome customers
started as G Suite customers,
which makes a lot of sense.
They've evolved and
are using the cloud
for their main
collaboration applications
and have really bought
in and invested there.
And so Chrome is a logical fit.
And we continue to
work across our teams
to figure out ways to bring
a unique value in this.
At the same time, we
have many, many customers
that deploy Chrome
browser, then Chrome OS,
and then start to
think about what
applications they could
be running in the cloud.
So it does go both ways.
And I think what
we really try to do
is bring the best
of both worlds here.
And a lot of times
it's customers
who are thinking about this.
But I think what
we definitely have
found is those of you that
have invested in G Suite
and have not deployed
Chromebooks, what it will do
is you will get more
out of your investment,
because you're really pushing
people to be cloud-enabled,
and it'll allow you to
get better value out
of those investments
you've made in the cloud.
A couple of examples before
I turn things over to Ravi,
that I think bring
this a bit to life.
Middlesex Hospital Health Care
is one of our target verticals,
has deployed Chromebooks
in a number of use cases.
I won't go through all
elements of the slide,
but, in essence,
they're deploying it
for many use cases.
As an example, nurses that
need ongoing compliance and HR
training that are coming in
multiple times of the day
and multiple
shifts, can leverage
Chromebooks either one-to-one
or in a shared environment
to get that training.
They're using it for EMTs.
So think about use cases
where every second matters.
Same type of thing for EMTs
to get the training they need,
but also to support
their day-to-day business
when they're out there
working with patients.
And at the end of
the day, again, it
goes back to that
customer experience.
It's all about how can the
patient experience be improved?
And if Chrome devices can help
from a productivity standpoint,
so they can spend more time with
their patients, it's a win-win.
And they're seeing
that in spades.
And are always looking for more
use cases to add Chrome to.
Ervia is a utility
company in Ireland.
And so you can imagine
the use cases here
in terms of highly distributed
workforce across the country
supporting a bunch of
different frontline workers
that are out in the field.
And Chrome has enabled them,
both from a grab-and-go, which
hopefully if you haven't seen
it here at the conference,
there's a series of
grab-and-go booths, where
you can essentially think
of it as loaner devices.
They're leveraging
these for folks
that may have lost
the device or just
any device for a couple of hours
to do their time-keeping, or HR
capabilities, or any
other applications they
need to access, as well as what
they need out in the field.
So again, Chrome is a great
enabler here for applications
that are not cloud-enabled.
They're also leveraging VDI.
So we've made a lot of
efforts over the years
to make sure, if you don't have
those applications in the cloud
yet, or maybe they're
not Android applications
because those are compatible
with Chrome as well,
VDI is a bridge that'll
help you get there as well.
A couple more.
Mercado Libre.
Latin America company in Mexico,
actually, that's flourishing;
leveraging Chromebooks for
contact centers, right?
So I think we really
think of contact centers
as a great frontline
worker segment.
We're seeing more
and more like Mercado
where this is a
outsourced function, one
that has a lot of
remote requirements,
and oftentimes IT does
not have the bandwidth
to support these
growing customer service
and contact agents.
And I think Mercado is a
great case of where they now
have contact center agents that,
again, can be up and running
within 6 to 10 seconds,
can really meet
the needs of their customer.
So in essence, they're happier,
so their customers are happier.
So again, a great use case.
It is one where we have
a number of companies
that are utilizing
this, and it's sort of
come to our attention.
Many of them were doing it
without us even knowing.
They just they just
stumbled on the use case.
And I think as more and more
contact center applications
move to the cloud, this
is an outstanding use case
to start with in
any organization.
And then the last
one before I turn
things over is Charles Schwab.
They've been a customer
a couple of years now.
It is a financial services
company, of course,
but think of it as very much
a retail frontline worker use
case, in that they have
deployed Chromebooks
across all their branches.
And really, like many of these
wealth management companies,
their goal is to really
empower their customers
to utilize the investment they
made in online applications,
both for financial
planning, portfolio
planning, and the like.
And so they have
deployed Chrome devices
so that anyone who
comes into the branch
can either work with a
representative on their wealth
planning, but ideally
that representative
turns a Chromebook around
and says, help yourself.
Here, this is where
you log in, this
is how you can utilize that,
so they can become much more
self-sufficient.
So hopefully you can
think of many use cases
within your organization that
are similar to that, which
have that element of helping
from a customer satisfaction
standpoint, but also helping
them serve themselves
by utilizing their
device as well.
So those are a few use cases.
Again, I just touched on sort
of the high-level pieces.
Obviously, we'll take some
questions here at the end,
but I think--
I'm really excited to
bring Ravi up here who
can speak a little
bit in depth on what
they're doing at Stitch Fix.
So if you could please
give him a warm welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
RAVINDRA SUNKU: Thank you.
Thank you, Mike.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Ravindra, the head
of IT at Stitch Fix.
I've been with Stitch Fix a
little over 2 and 1/2 years,
and we are, I would say,
a cloud native company.
That kind of puts it in
a very positive situation
when you would start looking
at the Chrome devices.
So we are a G Suite customer,
but our specific use case here
is in our warehouse operations.
I think for us at Stitch Fix,
would be fulfill products.
So how many of you
here in the audience
are customers of Stitch Fix,
that heard of Stitch Fix?
Raise of hands.
The rest of you, sign up.
[LAUGHTER]
So just to give you a little bit
of a snippet of how the Stitch
Fix business model works is that
as you complete your profile
we have product that's
already in our warehouses
that we algorithmically
pick and then present it
to a remote stylist.
The stylist takes that system
recommendation-- the algorithm
recommendations-- and then
picks the best products
suitable for you.
And then at that point
is where the handoff
happens to our warehouse
associates in our warehouses.
We have five
warehouses currently
in Stitch Fix that we
fulfill product in the US.
We are expanding into
UK this calendar year.
We started with the women's
business, launched the men's
and now we are doing kids.
So you have no excuse
not to sign up.
So the touch point from
a warehouse associate's
standpoint, it is not so much
about the Chrome, the G Suite
applications, it's
more the applications
that we built in-house for
our product fulfillment.
So think of it as
like a product--
like when you pick a
product in the warehouse.
So that is the use
case that we're using.
So we have, as I said, we have
five different warehouses.
We have workers that sign
into the applications
that they need to interact
with through a barcode scanner.
So what you can
see in this image
is the Chrome device attached
to our simple barcode scanner
and attached to a cart.
So the cart is where
we pick the product.
So we authenticate
through their badge
to put them into the profile
that they need to be.
And then from there, they
have the set of applications
that they're
authorized to access.
So all of our applications that
we use for the Chrome device
are browser native--
browser-based applications.
There's no client involved.
As far as Chrome
made a lot of sense
to put that on the front line.
So for us it is most not
only the cost effectiveness.
I think the ability to have
those applications easily
accessible.
So once you're authenticated,
you know the apps
that you need to use, and
they would essentially
push this cart around the
warehouse to pick product.
So it made it more
compelling for us
to use because I
think the battery
life, the cost of the devices,
all of those factored in as we
looked at these devices.
And it made the process
that much more easier.
So just to give you a
little bit of history
about when these Chrome
devices came into play,
it was not something that
was provisioned by IT.
IT had no involvement in it.
The operations and the
warehouse operations
were procuring these devices.
So we have over 2,400
devices in our portfolio.
And those are now--
in the past year, as we brought
on Chrome Enterprise device
management, IT has
now taken over it.
So we are managing
the end point,
we are managing the
plugins, and so on.
So it made a lot of sense
for us to use Chrome devices.
And we not only use
it in the warehouse,
but we also, when
workers change shifts
it just makes that interaction
that much more easier.
So the employee experience
there is consistent.
And they move from one
location to another location.
They don't take the
Chrome device with them.
They leave the cart there,
go to the next place,
sign out here, sign back in,
and then they continue to work.
And the add on value for
us was as we looked at--
because we are a G Suite
customer-- we have data
that we capture through
G Suite application,
so that either in Google
Sheets or a Google
Docs where the workers
that are in the facility
picking product, if
they are some QA issue
or whatever, they would go on
to toggle over to the Google
Sheets and then make notes in
there so that their supervisors
can interact with them.
So they are not only using
it for picking product,
it also works as a
collaborative device.
So we've standardized on the
Chrome browser at Stitch Fix.
So it's pretty
much everybody that
interacts with our
applications, both internal
or our public
cloud applications,
we are using Chrome as
the standard device.
As I shared earlier, the
Stitch Fix employee population
consists of like the
information or knowledge
workers, our customer
service warehouse associates,
and then we have our
remote stylists that
are working on their own
devices but they're working
remote, that work from home.
For us, standardizing
on a single browser
made a lot of
sense, and so we've
optimized our applications
to work well with Chrome.
We are current use
cases for us as I
shared earlier is
using Chromebooks
for warehouse workers.
And we're also evaluating
Pixel Books as an option
for our knowledge workers.
So interestingly, one of
our c-level executives
who came on board recently,
she challenged us,
say like, hey, how come you
get the provisioning Windows
and Mac devices, why
not Chrome devices?
Because she had
her own Chromebook,
she was used to it in the past,
and it just made sense for us
to kind of explore that.
So we are now exploring
Pixel Book as an option for--
as an alternate because
everything is in the cloud,
and they don't have a
lot of compute needs,
and it made it that
much more compelling
for us to put that in there.
So now that is slowly
part of our portfolio.
And we're also
currently evaluating
about standardizing on
Chromebooks for the stylists
who are currently on a BYOD.
Because we don't have visibility
to that end point held,
and that's, from a
security perspective,
is a bit challenging.
So we are exploring about
potentially making a Chrome
device available if the device
that the remote stylist has
today is not compliant, or it's
not up to speed, up to date.
So there's another extension.
So we started with
just the browser,
the warehouse workers now
looking at other use cases
as well.
I think one of the
things that I know
as customer service,
customer experience that
are important for
the organization,
far as employee experience
also is critical,
because these workers who
are interacting on the Chrome
browser, especially
at the warehouse,
we've set up kiosk
devices where people
can log in and deal with their
email or any of their employee
communication.
So it has helped us kind of
make that consistent message
across when they are on the
shop floor, versus when they're
in the office space,
when they need to attend
to HR or personal issues.
And for us it has been, I
think that the collaboration
capabilities is tremendous.
It just really helps
us keep up-to-date.
And so far we have no
reported security incidents.
So that's actually
comforting for us.
I can sleep well.
All right.
Mike, back to you.
I think we still
have plenty of time.
MIKE DAOUST: All right.
Great.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Ravi.
That was super.
And I think it's always
great to have a customer
sort of bring it to life.
And as you can tell from Ravi's
experience-- and a lot of it's
a testament to his
leadership-- is
that the use cases
have grown up not just
within the frontline segment,
but also the C-suite,
and really asking the questions
around why not move to Chrome?
Why not move things
more to the cloud?
Just given both the customer
experience as well as
the IT savings that's
associated with that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]